this is
unbelievable like I can't believe this
is happening Republican Senators decided
they don't want a bipartisan Bill to fix
the Border because what they actually
want is
chaos because that's what Donald Trump
says he
wants nice try Chris zero credibility
now we know the Republicans
overwhelmingly favor tough border
enforcement real border enforcement and
remember Eagle Pass used to be a place
where we had huge illegal border
crossings but guess what now an Eagle
pass we are actually seeing a huge
reduction in Texas in the illegal border
crossings why because we actually have
real enforcement taking place now the
governor says that the number has
actually dipped to single digits
crossing the border illegally from
several thousand all because they
actually enforced the Border something
the bid Administration refused es to do
joining me now Texas lieutenant governor
Dan Patrick Dan um your reaction to this
Democrat you know these talking points
that I think they wrote a couple of
months ago to blame Maga and Trump and
Republicans on chaos for chaos at the
border look President Biden is the chief
of chaos whether it's in the stock
market whether it's inflation whether
it's in the Border in our military in
our W culture he is he is the creator of
chaos not president Trump president
Trump had order On the Border in his
last couple of years and it was Secure
uh look this bill I've negotiated
thousands of bills as lieutenant
governor with Senators I know what the
Senators and the people want us to pass
I'm not going to bring forth a travesty
of a bill that's going to be voted down
and the people are going to be outraged
what the US Senate did and those
Republicans Langford and anyone who's
supporting that they ought to all be
voted out of office the next time they
run for office that bill is a joke as
you said it your your Ingram angle last
night was right on point uh this is I
can't think of a worse Bill Joe Biden
couldn't have written it any better
himself it would have guaranteed 5,000 a
day uh all the kind of
exceptions why these Republicans thought
anyone any any conservative any
Republican any person who believes in
securing the Border thought this was a
good idea is beyond me this this was the
worst piece of junk I've ever seen yeah
well it's it's dead now um and because
the people actually have an ability to
read just can't believe B it up Laur I
can't believe they even thought it would
pass yeah well Mitch McConnell thought
it'd do the big sneak didn't work out so
well um Dan uh we know that you all with
the razor wire and the increased
enforcement um National Guard troops and
so forth
now it looks like Eagle Pass which was
the sight of so much uh nightmarish
chaos with the migrants the reduction on
the number of migrants Crossing is out
unbelievably fantastic what
happened uh well we took it over from
the Biden border patrol and by the way
it's not the border patrol those men and
women they love Texas we love them they
want to take the handcuffs off and go
back to border enforcement instead of
being Hotel clerks but we took over that
area about 2 and 1 half miles between
two entry points Bridges and last month
2 to 3,000 a day some days more than
3,000 cross we put up the the barb wire
the concertina wire and those containers
and we put our National Guard out there
and laa it dropped to it is single
digits I was down there Friday a week
ago when Biden was threatening to come
down and cut the wire and we were ready
if they had their wire clippers we had a
lot more wire trust me we to put it
right back we from 3,000 to five or
people we know how to secure the Border
let the border patrol do their job let
us put wire all across the border the
buoys across the water turn it over to
Texas we'll have the son of a gun secure
in less than a week as Donald Trump will
when he becomes the next president
lieutenant governor thank you so much as
always hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere
else